the way that you connect with people
ahead of you is that you have to provide
them value so one of the stupidest
things you can do is ask someone how can
I provide you value it means that you
did no forethought and you're asking
them to do the work on your behalf so
wait a second some 19-year-old kid texts
me and says Alex I'll do anything I'll
pick up your coffee I'll do your you
know laundry or whatever I I'm willing
to work for free well honestly it would
cost me more to have the nuisance of
somebody always asking me questions
every day and thinking that me me
Consulting them every hour of the day is
a fair exchange for them getting me
coffee I'd rather just pay someone who
doesn't talk to me think about it and if
you can't think like that you're never
going to get to that level